welcome everyone to the lecture today
and learning from legends and today
legend is going to be a world champion
number 9 the grand Petrosyan and to who
is familiar with Tetris on what you can
what do you know about him the reason I
picked Pedro Sam because you know I'm
from Armenia he's from Armenia and I
went to his chest school and it is part
of the reason maybe why I play chance
because Pedro Sam because when he was a
world champion I was growing up and you
know it was a big is a big big thing in
Armenia in a small country having a
world champion you know he won in 1963
so Petros young world champion number 9
okay and who did Petro sound defeat to
become a world champion who knows that
yes oh feed button again yeah okay one
of the one you know he has won many
games at Petrossian if you don't know
his games you might be under the
impression that he was making a lot of
draws playing it safe
and things like that but when Peter was
Janet act you were in trouble that's
what a lot of people say when Pedro Xian
attacks you are in trouble because the
guy calculates all the way you know he
knows that his attack is going to be
successful he didn't attack too often
but when he attacked he usually win and
he not prepared two games to show you
today in this game in particular he is
going to defeat a very strong player in
just 21 moves and that player is Viktor
Korchnoi so you know see coach no lose
to any games in 21 moves and here he
lost against Petrosyan in a candidate
tournament back in a day 1962 when they
had these candidates tournaments this
was around 23 so there was a very long
tournament in so in around 23 petrosyan
defeated Korchnoi okay okay so let's
take a look at the game and I'll tell
you more stories about Petrossian
I mentioned earlier lecture that one of
the famous quotes is he said if somebody
is playing the Dutch defence against you
what you should do
don't stop him from doing that let him
play the Dutch you know because he won
every game he played against Dakshina
because he taught Dutch is not a sound
opening and basically he had a crushing
score early a lecture today if you
missed it we show a game that
Petrosyan won in nineteen moves against
the Finnish Grandmaster against the
Dutch defense and he had a huge score
against Dutch defense against Stonewall
I basically studied all the best games
he played because you know when I was
growing up I studied a lot of Petro
Siana Karpov games so here we see
against Kirchner he plays c4 and Petro
sound was more positional player and you
know he would play
he played efore also in the early stages
of his career but he played a lot of c4
and d4 so c4 c5 Knight f3 Knight f6 and
now he plays d4 pawn takes d4 94 he went
so we have in English setup here g6 I
goes nice e3 d5 you know it's probably
more common to play Bishop g7 here and
after that you will transpose into the
Hedgehog type of setup so this setup you
see on the screen here this is called
Hedgehog ok when you have the structure
with the E and C pawn D pawn is
exchanged with the C pawn this is that
structure ok usually basically why place
f3 castle Queen d2 and put rook FD 1 ok
C 1 and this is how white will set up
his pieces black usually castles plays
Bishop d7 rook c8 and tries to get the
development it's a you know probably
slightly better for white but black is
very solid so but here in this game a
cushion a very aggressive player he
played d5 he didn't play the Bishop g7
and here Pedro simply the interesting
move Bishop g5 idea behind it obviously
just to take on f6 and damage the
structure for cautionary and give him
some problems
so I think the idea was correct detects
c-4 III first block is making a lot of
pawn moves so far c5c takes d4 now D 5 D
takes c4 too many pawn moves already
have been played and now after e3 white
we just wants to take the pawn on c4 and
just castle and have a comfortable
position slightly better for example if
you play a Bishop d7 Bishop c4 castles
castle and you know a6 trying to play b5
a4 is a good move to stop it 9b d7 Queen
e2 enter if you had to evaluate this
position how would you evaluate this for
example so I want to give you a little
time to think before you say a white is
better okay but what are the reason you
think white is better here yes lead in
develop and absolutely that's very
important black is still struggling with
the development of this light square
bishop white is about to play rook f d1
mu k c1 he has complete development here
very quickly and actually I think it's
possible that Bach is going to have some
serious problems here so so that's why
white is better here but this is not
what caution we did caution I play the
dubious move Queen a 5 he is trying to
attack the bishop and play 94 but very
risky decision because you can't really
develop your queen too early like this
and expect that you're going to be fine
there are going to be problems here but
caution we probably underestimated
White's chances here so your Bishop is
under attack do you want to waste time
protecting it or you want to just get
rid of it and damage the structure
damage the structure Bishop takes f6 C
in chess a lot of times we make mistakes
because we don't play natural and simple
moves
we try to get creative and try to try to
do things that you shouldn't really do
just play simple if you try to play
simpler you'll make less mistakes so an
take now at the moment white his
three-piece is developed in a mean time
black structure is a little bit
questionable here in particular f7 is
very weak pawn here and he is behind in
development so he plays the move Bishop
before I guess Bishop g7 was recommended
by Horowitz and then trying to castle
but white is still better in my opinion
so Bishop before is played and now if
you just Castle then he can damage the
structure with Bishop takes c3 and then
you have a weak pawn it's not that much
fun so what move you can play first year
yes
rook c1 developing the rook developing
the rook and also ready now to capture
back with the rook on c3 now a6 another
dubious move Knapp castling for some
reason he should Castle here this was
recommended by another famous
Grandmaster sweating that in a black
shoe Castle he's still worse but it's
better for him suited a six he's trying
to control the b5 square now white
castles and now no longer if he castles
he is that safe because you go Knight d5
activating the night putting pressure on
f6 and as well on the bishop on before
here so we see now serious problems here
for black so caution I went Knight d7
and now what do we do here yes
Quimby 3 he's going to castle
Queen b3 he's going to castle what can
you do first here yes a3 questioning the
bishop if he takes on c3 rook takes c3
white is clearly better leading
development control of the C file pretty
soon very nice position but now he plays
Bishop e7 and now white to play who is
going to be able to play like petrosyan
here basically white is winning here and
he won the game quite convincingly
against caution from now on
I want to give chance everybody to think
late a bit yes absolutely agree yeah but
then it goes Queen d8 maybe and slow
castles Pollux king f7 King e8 yeah but
it's not so clear 95 Bishop takes Knight
yeah yeah that's like later later look
for that idea a little later okay
they're more preparatory work needed
here for that natural natural move here
yes will be three already suggested I
think yeah somebody suggested Queen b3 I
think will be three castles
yeah 95 is probably good but yeah then
he goes quindi 8 maybe or Bishop the age
probably quindi 8
maybe four
very good thinking before attacking the
Queen attacking the Queen now if the
Queen goes on the eight your idea works
Alex bishop f7 very powerful yes we
should consider the consequences of
Queen takes pawn and we also consider
the consequences of Queenie five as well
but this this is another very difficult
to calculate if you go here I think his
queen is getting probably trapped after
ninety five 1397 so Bishop d8 is forced
and I think we play route k1 here and
after this move time to resign so that's
what Petrosyan had in mind okay remember
yet that when the Queen gets in a
position like this will is surrounded by
many pieces opponent's pieces it's
likely you're going to get trapped okay
so you don't you never want to take a
pawn like this unless you have no choice
so he went Queen e5 but here is a very
powerful move here this is the this is
why I'm showing it again because of this
move because I don't think many players
would play this move including
grandmasters it's very tough move to
find
I think so even grandmasters would have
I would have a hard time probably play
the small because you know it's not easy
not easy F for sacrifice the pawn with
check playing like petrosyan gentleman
correct wait you guys have the trespass
there oh okay okay okay
both both players have computers so it
you know so F for actually a queen takes
c3 losses on the spot because you just
go king h1 and now you have three
different threats rook f3 rook e1 and 95
yeah this is again probably caution I
wanted to forget you know because it's
it's bad enough and so Queen Queen b8
only move
now yes
then he castles don't let him castle
okay we don't want to let him castle
anymore here you must play energetically
now Castle August don't let castle yes
correct
exclamation mark he takes follow it up
check correct well let's take a look
if it goes King g7 we give a little
check if it goes King g8 quickly 30
seconds can you find a way the King g8
in your head yes okay then Queen f7
comes in correct and if you ghost King
h6 quickly
what's the winning move rook f3 ruk h3
yes
checkmate alright so now he played King
to e8 it's not that obvious I mean it is
it's winning but it's not like
completely obvious how is it winning you
know
yes I think he wants to go Knight d5 now
activating the night because now the
threat is to play 9c 7 check checking
the King and they're putting the other
night only six so it goes Bishop d6 and
now black can barely move here now these
pieces can really move here he's like
trapped in this position
we need more forces here we need more
forces here to finish a mafia very very
promising position but need to finish
him up here yes absolutely 96-97 is
coming here but I cannot really move
anything night on December cannot move
f6 is hanging really stuck so it plays
b5 and now 97 correct King is 7
continue now I played 94 this is a tough
move to find because you really want to
take this but actually the best move is
94 because now you're threatening to
play a 96 check winning the Queen and
also you're ready to jump in now with
the Queen only six creating two threats
so goes King f8 and now
please
before we go Queenie six I think we
should take the net rope here take the
rook so he resigned here because if he
takes
now Queen is six if he plays Bishop e7
what is the winning move after Bishop e7
which more wins the game on the spot 96
correct and the bishop is not
protectable he cannot go to c7 he cannot
go to be eight c8 is hanging so Queen B
it is the only move and now again
cautionary sign in the video of this
variation but still what could have been
done yes excellent Queen goes here and
winning move is
Knight to e5 it's possible there what's
the better version of that jump that
will attack more things 95 you might
lose the screen but get a couple of
pieces then he could maybe fight night
night
eise Evan now the queen is under attack
and c8 is under attack the game is over
okay and that's why he won the game so
he resigned he resigned after this move
here I think 98 okay so this is a
candidates tournament 1962
Petrosyan vs. Kirchner one of the
quickest defeats public ocean I had a
nice masterpiece a miniature by Pedro
Xian again he a lot of his games yeah
maybe they would be dry a lot of drawers
but he also had many many spectacular
games you know that he won against very
strong players one of his best games is
actually Petro sambhaavana game from the
World Championship I don't remember the
exact game I think it's game 24 or 25
it's the one that he has a King March
starting from E to White King March
starts only two ends up on g8 in the end
game and battle Enix simply resigns you
know and it was just incredible to see
this game so you know I can maybe find
this game that that's that's another
game but so this is the cautionary game
any questions regarding this game
everybody understand okay now we're
going to move forward to the next game
that I have prepared and this is
actually played in the Olympiad 1970
Olympiad okay and this is Petrossian
against you know a player 24 25 and
again 1970 24 25 it was a it was a
pretty strong rating because back then
the
now many people had read the rating
civil so this person is Vargas Rodriguez
probably a grandmaster so let's take a
look here how Pedro shan't defeat him
here in just 20 moves Olympiad and of
course Petra Champlain many Olympiads on
USSR team as I mentioned earlier Armenia
was part of USSR and USSR when they play
this Olympiads they were just
unstoppable because you had all the best
players from the region from Ukraine
from Latvia from Estonia Armenia all the
best players they could select and they
would come up with a team that is just
basically they're the best players in
the world and they're just playing on
the same team it's a you know it's like
you have the chance to put let's say now
you put our own yarn
kramnik even choked you put in one team
in all these players and they would be
very very strong and back then again
most strong players they came from USSR
so it's probably just a feature that was
just from us and the rest of the best
players were from USSR c4 e6 Knight f3
why does why play Knight f3 here who
knows the reasoning of Knight f3 here
yes
avoiding the nimzo-indian defense if you
play Knight c3 here likely your opponent
go to the bishop before the cost at the
point of this setup so now they switch
back to this it could be a qgd Queens
gambit declined or it could be a semi
Slav qgd or semi Slav yes
huh you could play three but you can
also play 93 just developing the night
okay
c6 III 9 bt 7 this is a setup that I
play actually played quite a few games
here at a club in a US Championship in
this position I play Bishop d3 here this
is my setup here and was shown to me by
my good friend Gabrielle sarkeesian he
is the big expert of this lines so he
taught me the Bishop d3 line I played in
2009 US Championship the first US
Championship held here I played maybe
three or four games in that championship
in this line very good results but here
okay this is a more modern Bishop d3
setup nineteen seven they probably
didn't know too much about the Bishop d3
so he played the classical b3 b5 black
is trying immediately to break the
center it's possible to play this move
it leads to a slightly worse position I
actually played this move once against
Graham massugu Levitch Demetri GUI which
and slightly worse position so it's
probably the castle is recommended
Castle b6 Bishop d7 this is the setup b6
Bishop e7 after you Castle White is a
little bit better maybe but victory it's
really not so much popular anymore it's
usually people just go Bishop d3 here
nowadays if you look at the top so after
a 5 years you need to actually take on
d5 here it's very important the key line
here is take take a yeah tick sorry
take take Knight d5 now that need to
check this is bad because you run into
Bishop a3 and then your King remains in
the middle of the board so if they
Bishop d2 check then he goes here takes
and this is considered slightly better
for white
Oh gates playable playable for black but
you know so but here for some reason
play with the black pieces Rodriguez
whether or not maybe he wasn't familiar
with the theory because he committed the
inaccuracy he took on d4 and yeah this
is not a very good move because now I
can just simply take on d4 and now the
problem is if you take like this you run
into a very unpleasant there are several
ideas but this this in particular very
unpleasant Knight f5 now your Bishop is
hanging and your pawn is hanging so you
have to go back and I fit in after
Bishop f2 your let's say not in very
good shape here because what do you do
next
you know you don't want to play g6
that's weakening your position
I'm ready to play rook d1 and even take
the pawn on d5 long Castle is also
consideration here actually to go for
immediate victory with we should be five
so it's a you know thinks went wrong you
know simply here for black so he decided
here his better off just giving up the
pawn so he played castle but he takes c6
and now he goes ninety five see this is
this is a good example for you not to
get greedy you know some players when
they win the pawns they just want to
keep trying winning meaning more plants
but here taking on b7 would have been a
positional mistake because after Bishop
b7 you know he's got some development
leading development you might still be
ok here but he's got the rook c8 coming
up and this is probably what Rodriguez
was aiming for against Petrossian to get
some lead in development but that's not
what's going to happen here because
Petra sham is up one pawn and remember
safety was key for Petrus young you know
he rather he'd be one point up than two
but make sure the opponent has no
conscience
so don't be too attached about winning
lot of puns so just play Bishop e2
simply developing
he takes on c6 Bishop b2 up one pawn
queen a5 now what would you do in this
position what is black really trying to
do here after Queen a5
he is trying to do something but what
yes
excellent thinking very good if you play
short castle here that's going to be a
problem because you might be able to
develop an unexpected attack on you with
Knight g4 okay it's not so clear if this
exactly works but at least it looks
threatening okay so I played h3c not
even allowing that preventing everything
so Knight g6 and now castle castle where
we could castle on two different places
here which one we want to go to which
one is the best yes Castle queenside
correct because now his bishop is also
hanging on d6 on x-ray and also c6 pawn
is hanging as well okay
and now the bishop is under attack we
should be 7
now what do you do there is a loose
piece right bishop is loose on d6 the
problem with that is he takes back you
take on d6 he takes on g2 and then you
start losing some material and then the
C file can really backfire on you
because your King is there so actually
you want this pawn to remain there you
want the C pawn to remain there because
that's your shield okay that's your
shield against potential threats on a C
file yes absolutely 96 attacking the
rook rook moves you take the bishop so
he takes we take now this is really bad
now pawns are weak equals e v
now
so we need to get the last piece into
the game correct that rook is sitting
there not doing anything you bring it in
now ghost Knight to d5 trying to block
the file now activate your pieces
and now
now winning move here absolutely that's
petrosyan sacrifice the exchange now he
takes and his opponent resigned because
he cannot take on c3 here because it's
simply a checkmate now what's going to
happen next is Knight takes d5 pawn
takes d5 Bishop e5 comes in and mating
threat on g7 so he cannot do anything
here as well so quick defeat an
important win for the Petrossian and the
USSR team at the 1970 Olympiad and let's
take a look at this game this is the
semi slob opening okay so this shows you
how to play against the semi Slav if
they play the early breakthrough idea
okay
is it pretty clear for everyone in this
room why he resigned here or is it still
a little bit unclear
hmm yeah basically yeah basically what
what's going to happen as 94-95 is it
coming as well so let's say you play
this move rook HEA they're they're
probably a lot of ways to win here but I
particularly like this 94-95 idea
because then there is a mate on h7 and
so let's say he takes that's just just a
beautiful line I want to show you Knight
g5 threatening checkmate on g7 Knight f6
and who is going to find a winning move
here this is the example of the
overworked piece here the move that wins
the game instantly there are many moves
that are winning we're not just finding
a wins we're finding the instantaneous
win here go 94 maybe bash instant move
here by Petrosyan Alex absolutely
correct threatening checkmate this is
called overworked piece okay now you're
threatening checkmate if it tries to
defend it then it's smothered mate he's
made it and if it takes defender is gone
Queen h7 checkmate okay so that's why he
resigned and this is probably the best
thing what black can do here and but he
still loses here no matter what so again
the topic we covered today it was you
know learning from legends and - I know
you've had a few other legends you did
already but this was Petrosyan world
champion number nine originally from
Armenia and you know I was born in
Armenia and I attended the chess club
that is named after Petrosyan and you
know a very very strong player of course
and you know anyone who became world
champion I mean you know especially very
competitive years at that time he had to
win against very strong players so it
was very very competitive and you know
he he remained a very strong player and
at the top he was the world
one for six years yes it was hit very
well and you know very interesting style
positionally but also where the games
are showing here
positional but at the right time he was
ready to attack
see when opportunity presented here see
a lot of players here would just take on
d5 years see not too many people take on
g6 people would take on d5 with a second
plan win the game that's another way to
win this more you know safer way to win
it but rook g6 is the strongest way to
win it it's not an absolute necessary
thing to do you can just take on d5
didn't win but you know he was ready he
didn't attack two of them but whenever
he attacked you know a lot of games he
won by you know very nice mating ideas
and you know tactical ideas were just he
just blew away his opponents very strong
positionally as well maybe in some point
some of the lectures will show some that
I will show some Petrosyan games just
purely on positional today was morally
showing you some masterpieces where he
won in just 20 moves basically